so when you first heard about Burning
Man and then you actually go with your
whole group of 25 collaborators how did
you come away from it I realized it's
different because you were fifty percent
filming and then fifty percent
participated in it how did you added you
come away from it personally well I
think my experience was probably
different than a lot of other people's
experience during during production it's
easy to summarize production as chaos
imagine a film set but you're getting
destroyed by windstorms emotions of
others yeah it's like it's a 24-hour you
know project so at two in the morning
you're out dancing or at six in the
morning you're filming a sunrise I
remember like getting like probably a
half hour an hour nap and then we're out
there with the red camera to shoot the
sunrise all the way past temple it's
huge I mean we're talking miles and
miles and miles of desert and so it's
it's not like okay I'm going to walk to
the set you know it's like I'm going to
figure out how to ride the bike I'm
gonna you know get an art car there's
amazing art cars out there where you can
like hitch a ride and and people will
kind of travel at five miles per hour on
these art cars that will go around the
playa but you know I came away with it
with this project that was in a very
uncertain circumstance at the end we
knew that we had captured a lot of
footage we knew that a lot of people had
had a really messed-up time we knew that
some people captured the most amazing
experiences on camera did we have enough
you know what how do you now you have to
start going through the footage and we
ended up with something like 400 hours
of footage on the different cameras that
we had out there so it was you know my
experience was on these hard drives you
know from all these different different
cameras and so putting that together
became the task so you're leaving there
where a lot of people might have closure
about certain experiences in their lives
or part of themselves but you now have
this
that you have in a backpack yeah and and
so that did that way on you a little bit
i mean it would probably keep me up at
night i would be yeah it's one thing to
be on set for a week and then have 51
weeks of life or whatever else you're
doing for me just it just hasn't stopped
it's been five years of getting this
film finished and and for me because I
ended up basically being the editor on
the project I got to relive the
experience every day all day long for
four months and months and months and
months you know week experience except I
got to experience that week I don't know
30 weeks 50 weeks of it over and over
again I've watched the film probably
close to 50 times so you got everybody's
SD card or whatever with you or they
sent them to you later yeah out on the
playa we actually had a couple laptops
and a couple different hard drives that
were part of the team and some hard
drives for all the red footage so we
come in with these these hard drives
from the red cameras every day is like
actually two times a day we'd come in
and we drop off 150 new gigabytes of red
footage and and then clear the hard
drives off we'd have two sets so they'd
be in two different places yeah go back
at it so we had a lot of SD cards and we
didn't have enough because an SD card
back then was an hour of footage you
know we shot with the 16 gigabyte SD
cards the new with the biggest SD cards
the most expensive SD card 16 gigabytes
well we had back then and some of the
film was shot at 720p the small cameras
and yeah we would transfer transfer
footage and it was tough I think we
ended up losing I think three SD cards
that had the most profound footage the
most remarkable footage on it the most
incredible personal experiences gone
just lost and that's the problem when
you're working with media now it's so
small these are the last car
I remember it's like you know you can
lose an SD card but so it's tough you
got to work with what you have and so we
ended up with all these hard drives I
think six or eight terabytes of our raw
material I think that might have been a
copy so yeah you get to work with him
Wow do you remember the day that you sat
down and began like day one of editing
it was tough I think you know editing
for the project was difficult process
because the idea is that it was
participatory and so the Mojo and the
idea was like oh man you know we're all
collaborating and we're all going to
kind of put this film together so like
okay you know originally we had paid
someone to do some editing and that that
ended up being really didn't quite work
out so we ended up doing trying to do
some editing ourselves and kind of some
people did amazing edits with their
footage but then it was sort of like
okay but if we need you know how do you
put together something if only a couple
people have their puzzle pieces on the
table so it wasn't quite ready to like
put the puzzle pieces together because
we didn't quite have enough so then it
was sort of like well we're trying to
put together the puzzle and we need the
pieces so we got to finish the pieces
first and was kind of interesting
because each person had a different
experience out there and so yeah editing
kind of just didn't go so well I
actually went out to the east coast for
a bit and I worked with some of the
people involved in the project for
several weeks putting together the edits
and working with people and I think it's
just difficult because so much time has
passed this was 2008 so people's lives
are busy people move on and stuff like
that and so really because I made that
promise ultimately was my responsibility
to finish so ultimately like I had to
like get the film edited which was a
whole different process but yeah i SAT
for months I got the edit together and
kind of came back turned off the
internet and started as november two
thousand
2012 2011 geez three or four months
solid to get that assembly edit together
and I remember assembly at it was 23
hours right so 400 hours down to 23
hours on a single timeline right 23 our
rough assembly at it you're trying to
make a 90-minute film oh gosh so yeah
try to take 23 hours all right you
already did it from 423 now I got to
take 23 down to like two or 90 minutes
it's crazy so yeah it took the assembly
edit down to a rough cut in like May
2012 and then took the rough cut down to
the fine cut down an you know August and
then finally have the final cut finally
finished 85 minutes
you